now we might be 10 months away from the
midterm elections but we saw today
democrats are already trying to tip the
scale in their favor looking to push as
many as 120 republicans off the ballot
hillary clinton's former campaign
attorney tweeted out this prediction
saying this before the midterm election
we will have a serious discussion about
whether individual republican house
members are disqualified by section 3 of
the 14th amendment from serving in
congress we may even see litigation here
to react missouri gop senator josh
hawley now senator i'm going to you
first on this because you were supposed
to be the man at the center of this they
said you're the one who left these
people to the capitol you're the first
person on that hit list so what is your
response
well i think it's absolutely absurd and
it's all part of the politics of fear
that is all the democrat party has to
offer this country they've governed this
way for an entire year this is the party
that turned the fbi on parents at school
board meetings this is the party that
says that you're a domestic terrorist if
you question their policies this is the
party that has worked overtime to
de-platform conservatives to silence
them to shut down free speech it's crazy
what they're trying to do and the reason
they're doing it lawrence is they're not
popular the american people see their
agenda they reject their agenda they
reject the crime wave that this party
the democrat party is responsible for
all across the country the inflation the
the out of control spending they reject
all of that the democrats know that and
come november i think the american
people are going to have their say so
what are you going to do to fight for
the american people because it's one
thing for the people that actually
committed uh acts of violence that
rioted but there's even been a movement
to go after people that were just there
they were at the rally earlier that they
didn't even go to the capitol they want
to know if their elected officials are
going to protect their civil liberties
yeah that is that is such a great point
and let me just say this it is a
constitutional right to engage in
peaceful political demonstrations and
the thousands tens of thousands of
people who came to washington last
january 6 and have now been harassed by
the fbi
have had people knock on their doors and
threaten them that is crazy and it is
wrong it is wrong to go after
law-abiding citizens who are engaging in
their constitutional rights and i will
continue to fight that at every turn and
listen you know on january 6th a year
ago i objected to the state of
pennsylvania because they didn't follow
their own election laws their supreme
court changed the rules of the voting
during the election that was wrong then
it is wrong today i hope we never see
that again in american history but to
attempt to use that as an excuse and to
use last january 6 as an excuse to go
after law-abiding citizens and shut down
speech you don't like that's just plain
un-american and that's what this
administration is trying to do and
lawrence i can tell you they're not
going to get by with it the american
people aren't going to stand for it
senator only got a few seconds left with
you will you be on the ballot this
upcoming
election cycle
not until 2024 is when i'm on the ballot
again in the state of missouri and uh i
look forward to serving the people of
missouri in the next two years we've got
a lot to do and it begins with standing
up to joe biden's anti-democratic
anti-constitutional agenda and if
there's a move to take you off the
ballot what would be your response
that's not going to happen lawrence i
mean
i tell you what it would be you talk
about an assault on democracy for this
democrat party to try and tell the
american people that conservatives and
republicans cannot be on the ballot i
mean it really does show what they want
they want a one-party state that's what
they want and they want to silence
anybody who disagrees with them but
that's not america that's been tried
before in our history it hasn't
succeeded and it's not going to succeed
now josh hawley thanks so much for
stopping by hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else